[Music]
some kids just have a certain look about
them kind of like you've seen them
before we found 10 kids who totally look
like Disney characters the last one on
our list is the most iconic Disney
look-alike ever stay tuned to find out
who it is if you like Disney as much as
we do subscribe to the things channel to
get up-to-date videos on all things
Disney and click the thumbs up button if
you liked this video now here are ten
kids who totally look like Disney
characters linguine from ratatouille
ratatouille is a story about a young
dreamer who has high hopes of becoming a
chef someday the only problem is he's a
rat and rats aren't usually welcome in
restaurants thankfully Remi has the help
of an up-and-coming cook by the name of
linguini together they create dishes
that Paris falls in love with all while
winning over the toughest critic in the
city well you're not going to believe
how much this kid looks exactly like
linguini from their hair to the nose to
the smile the resemblance is spot-on
seriously if they ever make a
live-action version of this film they
should call this kid in for an audition
Russell from up there has never been a
more unlikely pair than Russell and mr.
Fredricksen from the movie up from the
beginning mr. Fredricksen was grumpy and
distant from the young scouts but the
little guy was never swayed well and he
was pretty much stuck on the old man's
porch when the house took off with all
those balloons still the two helped each
other be better versions of themselves
all while saving a weird bird named
Kevin who was really a ladybird who had
a bunch of babies well if there was a
look-alike contest
this kid totally know that he even got
the sash with all the merit badges so
non-flash from Zootopia who can forget
Flash
he's the sloth that Judy Hopps and Nick
Wilde and needed to get information from
at the Department of Motor Vehicles side
note that's a hilarious commentary on
the pace over at the DMV this sloth is a
hilarious opposite to Judy's fast
Hawking high-energy we've really thought
her ears were going to explode when Nick
told flash that joke this is a totally
random reference but it's too funny not
to point out check out this girl who
looks almost identical to zootopia's
flash she has the same facial expression
and everything
some would just tell her a joke hero
from big hero 6
big hero 6 was an incredible film about
the triumphs of a boy genius and his
healthcare robot after suffering the
devastating loss of his brother everyone
loved the superhero elements of this
film and fans absolutely adored baymax
it only makes sense that young fans
would want to look like hero and maybe
even invent like him to enter this kid
okay sure
that hair is probably a wig but look at
the little dude's face it looks like he
was plucked directly out of the movie
and dropped into the real world our
question is can this guy invent
microbots to Jack Jack from The
Incredibles
Jack Jack is making a big splash in The
Incredibles - for such a little baby he
sure does have a lot of big powers this
kid can shoot lasers out of his eyes
turn into a heavy lead ball
spontaneously combust and turn into the
weird purple monster guy but his biggest
superpower has got to be cuteness just
look at him well as it turns out a
blogger from Utah has a baby that looks
exactly like Jack Jack right down to the
cute little hair point on top Dani
Christensen said his co-workers pointed
this out and he couldn't agree more
Pinocchio alrights we know that this is
a Halloween costume and is intended to
make a child look like her favorite
Disney character that it's just too cute
not to mention in this list introducing
the real live version of Pinocchio this
little girl has the Hat the red circles
on her cheeks the big blue bow white
gloves and strings on her hands will
admit anyone can pick those things up at
a costume shop but what you can't pick
up is the hair the blue eyes and the
wide eyed expression of wonder on her
cute little face Jiminy Cricket we've
got to say there are a lot of infants
who look like they're about 90 years old
but we came across one that actually
looks like a beloved Disney character
they're both short well-dressed and
hopeful about life so who do you think
this little guy looks like we think he
looks a lot like Jiminy Cricket they
even have a similar expression on their
faces do you think this little dude is
also going to convince a puppet that he
is its conscience or maybe he's just a
cute bowtie-wearing baby we found on the
Internet
Merida from brave with her unruly
her strength and her defiance Merida won
the hearts of young girls all over the
world
she's a very unique princess and way
ahead of her time she can shoot a bow
and arrow and she loves adventure we
found one girl who really resembles this
strong fiery princess this young girl's
mom couldn't help but snap and share
this pic of her little girl she compared
it side-by-side to a picture of Merida
with the caption saying she thinks her
daughter looks like Merida from brave we
couldn't agree more our question is just
how good is she with a bow and arrow
Andy from Toy Story Andy is the beloved
little boy from the Toy Story movies who
all the toys longed to be with forever
all the characters had his name written
on the bottom of their shoes Andy loves
and plays with the toys for years until
it's time for him to go to college then
he must decide what to do with his toys
the Canada's picture must have been sold
a bunch of times that he looks like Andy
from Toy Story 3 otherwise he wouldn't
have posed the exact same pose as this
frame from the movie although the kid
looks a bit too melancholy to be Andy
smile kid you've got a woody and a buzz
doll Walt himself this has got to be the
best thing we found on the Internet in a
while and we spend a lot of time on the
Internet this little boy's mom posted a
picture of him saying that she told him
he could be any Disney character he
wanted on their family trip he chose the
most iconic of them all
seriously give this kid a medal just
look at that determined hopeful look on
this kid's face he is probably inventing
the theme park and movie franchises of
the future right now way to go little
guy we hope you accomplish all your
dreams and that was ten kids who look
like Disney characters thanks for
watching see you later
[Music]